okay so we've been talking for the last
couple of weeks about what's called
softy monetization on YouTube and I've
told you that two years ago when there
was the big ad pocalypse on YouTube our
entire channel was demonetised this
meant that none of our videos none of
our then 12000 or so videos that we had
on YouTube none of them were running ads
so our revenue went down 99 percent
overnight and slowly sort of recovered
over the last two years
until about a month ago at which point I
started noticing more and more of our
videos marked as not brand safe meaning
that the channel is not demonetised the
video is not strictly speaking to
monetize but it's placed in a limited
monetization state and effectively ads
don't run on it on individual videos and
I got a bunch of emails when I talked
about this I think it was on Monday
maybe Tuesday from people saying David
can you give us some examples of the
videos you've done that have been marked
as not brand safe or age restricted and
demonetized on YouTube and the answer is
yes I'm going to give you a few examples
of these videos and you will see very
very quickly that what is going on is
absolutely ridiculous we did a video a
couple of weeks ago about Jordan
Peterson speaking at Liberty University
it is video of Jordan Peterson and three
other people sitting and talking on the
stage at Liberty University that video
has been determined to not be suitable
for most advertisers we did a video
called
what do extremists expect Trump to do
for them there is nothing gory there are
no descriptions of violence it is just
me talking about what it is about Donald
Trump that has appealed to extremists
that video has been demonetized another
video about that kid Jacob Wall who was
caught faking his own death threats he's
that Trump troll who was caught faking
his own death threats that video has
been demonetized I discussed with you a
couple of weeks ago how Donald Trump
went on the offensive on
Twitter going after quote complicated
airplanes after the Boeing 737 eight max
max eight crash that video with nearly a
hundred thousand views has been
demonetised Tucker Carlson is right not
to apologize a video where I just
explained why if your Tucker Carlson and
your audience is the Fox News audience
you wouldn't apologize for what he said
on a radio show
ten years ago demonetised I did a video
about a Republican congressman
threatening Donald Trump's former
personal attorney Michael Cohen widely
covered by corporate media demonetised
for the David Pakman show on YouTube I
did a clip about conspiracy theorist
mark dice sending me private messages on
Twitter and attacking me nothing gory
nothing violent no descriptions of
violence it was all about edits to his
Wikipedia page seventy six thousand
views demonetised I did a video where I
just played a voicemail from a viewer
obsessed with so-called sjw's social
justice warriors also he monetized and I
did a video about the anti-vaccine
movement and how the anti-vaccine
movement has caused a measles outbreak
that video also demonetised
these are just a few examples I spent 90
seconds finding these yesterday just
these videos represent 400,000 views on
our channel for which we earned no money
now here's what you really need to
understand most YouTube channels don't
get 400,000 views in a year okay
statistically 400,000 views is more than
most YouTube channels get in a year we
have 400,000 views just from these nine
videos in the last few weeks which have
been demonetized and no money has been
earned whatsoever so you know we have a
couple options Pat and you and I always
talk about this privately we talk about
is this video likely to be demonetized
we still do every story that we think
needs doing but we are aware
of videos that are likely to be
demonetised and usually it's like if we
talk about Syria if we talk about war we
don't even have those conversations
anymore Pat because anything is likely
to de monetize like this stuff I can't
predict it anymore I don't know if you
can but at this point it's anything goes
to be demonetised I certainly can't
predict it and I would imagine that
corporate media is covering a lot of
these stories as well but I would also
imagine that they're not getting
demonetized when they decide to cover
the stories so we've thought about a few
different things one would be just up
ending the channel altogether like maybe
we could start doing cooking videos or
like movie reviews instead of politics
and news because those topics are often
controversial yeah so obviously we're
not going to do that and we are going to
continue simply trying to grow our
membership support okay so thanks to
everybody who's been signing up as a
result of this new D monetization you
can go to david pakman.com slash
membership to sign up we're talking
about a couple bucks a month if you use
the coupon code this is 20/20 I don't
want to nor have we ever made decisions
about what topics to cover based on
monetization and that's why we want to
continue building our membership support
so I can say YouTube D monetization who
cares we've got more than enough support
from the audience so please consider
signing up